ben je suis en détenstion comme dans la
vie de tous les jours je suis pas le bon
Dieu ni la
[Musique]
diabolique
c'était un feuilleton C cette histoire
c'était c'était un roman on l'a souvent
appelé Simon par son prénom et pas Simon
Weber parce que bon c'est un personnage
un peu de roman populaire les journaux
de la presse locale titré la diabolique
aux
assises une mamie qui s'amuse à faire
des coups de sécurité comme les grands
voyou le font quand ils vont sur des
braquages ou autesagit comme ça c'est
qu'elle a quelque chose à se reprocher
je me demande comment elle peut dormir
et comment elle peut peut encore se
regarder dans une
glace on était un peu comme un vieux
couple alors parfois on se disputait
parfois c'était beaucoup plus plus calme
je suis pas le bon Dieu ni la
diabolique je peux vous dire que jusqu'à
son dernier souffle elle essaiera encore
d'établir son
innocence l'affaire Simone Weber c'est
un crime sauvage incarné par le visage
d'une gentille petite grand-mère c'est
le meurtre de Bernard etier 55 ans son
ancienne amant tué et qu'elle aurait
découpé avec une meuleuse à béton
l'affaire Simon Weber c'est une enquête
complexe une instruction fleuve et un
procès spectaculaire et théâtral qui a
passionné la presse et les Français
durant des
semaines Simon Weber a joué pendant des
années une partie d'échec macabre avec
un juge d'instruction obstiné à avec son
juge
gilbertil près de 25 ans après sa
condamnation qui est devenu Simone Weber
que sont devenus les proches de la
victime quel regard portent les
policiers les avocats les journalistes
sur cette affaire
avecali nous avons décidé de retrouver
les protagonistes à commencé par Simon
Weber et d'analyser avec eux les
conséquences et les répercussions de ce
dossier hors
norme
[Musique]
France 20 ans de réclusion criminelle
pour Simon Weber reconnu responsable de
la mort de Bernard etier l'accusé était
absente à la lecture du
verdict tout commence 6 ans plus tôt le
22 juin
1985 Bernard etier contre maître de 55
ans divorcé et père de deux filles vit
seul à Maxeville dans la bonlieue de
Nancy cela fait plusieurs jours qu'il
n'a plus donné de nouvelles à sa fille
Patricia je suis venue voir s'il était
dans sa maison
il y était pas et j'ai sonné et voyant
que j'inistais donc les voisins en face
m'ont recueilli en me disant bah venez
rentrreer c'est là qui m'ont expliqué
qu'ils avaient vu Simon VEB partir
samedi matin avec
Papa Simone Weber c'est une femme qui
entretient une liaison orageuse avec
Bernard etier depuis 3 ans d'ailleurs ce
samedi-là les voisins de bernardtier ont
observé un drôle de Manège les voisins
ont entendu un peu d'éclat de voix le
voisin qui est un peu curieux s'est
approché il a entendu qu'il se disputait
bon il a pas insisté il est reparti et
peut-être un quur d'heure après il les a
vu partir tous les deux en voiture
chacun avec leur
voiture depuis ce matin du 22 juin plus
personne n'a revu Bernard
[Musique]
[Rires]
Itier
Patricia étier c'est vous qui lancez
l'affaire pourquoi est-ce bizarre que
votre père ne donne pas de nouvelles
parce que à l'époque j'avais une
relation avec papa qui était assez
fusionnel on se voyait une fois par
semaine donc où je téléphonais où je
passais et donc là plusieurs semaines
sans nouvelles donc je me suis un petit
peu inquiétée je trouvais que c'était
pas normal il était dans quel état
d'esprit bon il était bien bon sauf que
Madame Weber le harcelait déjà à
l'époque elle était toujours devant sa
porte à n'importe quelle heure du
travail elle le suivait même jusqu'à son
travail elle le suivait à à sa sortie du
travail elle venait devant chez lui
jusqu'à ce qu'il ouvre la porte quoi
donc vous alertez la police que vous
dit-on
bah on me croit pas trop parce que c'est
vrai que vu laage Mo papa on peut faire
une fugue on peut disparaître on peut
vouloir s'éloigner on
peut donc vous allez décideré de
donenquêter vous-même par quoi est-ce
que vous commencez par la suivre alors
je me suis grimée hein je vous dis pas
parce que comme elle le connaissait donc
je la suivais avec un foulard une
perruque je pensais qu'elle allait me
mener quelque part qu'elle allait
m'emmener une cachette ou je sais pas ou
chez quelqu'un que je connaissais pas et
que j'aurais peut-être pu trouver papa
mais non elle faisait que les
aller-retours dans ses deux appartements
donc euh et si on sonnait elle répondait
pas de toute façon
donc Bernard etier était peut-être
harcelé par Simone Weber parce qu'il
avait une nouvelle compagne Monique nuus
elle aussi s'inquiète quand elle reçoit
un étrange appel dont son fils Didier se
souvient encore
[Musique]
aujourd'hui didiénus au soir du 22 juin
votre mère reçoit un coup de fil anonyme
que dit-il il dit que Bernard va va pas
rentré comme convenu ils avaient prévu
de partir ensemble en weekend et elle
n'a pas du tout cru cette personne qui
est au bout du fil c'est un homme une
femme c'était un homme qui se faisait
passer pour un un ami de
Bernard donc on a trouvé ça bizarre et
elle m'a
envoyé tout de suite prendre des
nouvelles essayer de voir s'il était pas
chez lui déjà dans un premier temps à
maxville et comme on avait quelques
renseignements concernant Simone
Weber je suis allé aussi aux autres
domiciles de de Simone et qu'est-ce que
Bernard etier vous a dit de cette femme
qu'il fallait s'en méfier que s'il lui
arrivait quoi que ce soit ça pouvait
venir que
d'elle et on a pris peur parce que
quelques semaines précédent on avait eu
l'arrivée de Bernard complètement
enensouqué comme drogué à la maison qui
trouvait à peine son chemin et j'avais
pu remarquer que il avait une marque de
piqûre dans le bras donc on suppose
qu'il avait été drogué et on a tout de
suite pensé que il aurait pu arriver la
même chose voir pire donc vous allez
mener un peu votre enquête vous allez
devant chez Simon qu'est-ce que vous
découvrez qu'est-ce qui se passe unanci
avenue de Strasbourg j'ai
sonné le rideau du premier étage a bougé
ça n'a pas répondu sur le parking
quasiment en face j'ai découvert fermé à
clé la Renault 9 bleu de de Bernard je
su repassé plus tard dans dans la soirée
il faisait nuit et là il y avait plus y
plus de voiture de Bernard
elle avait
disparu mais où est passé la Renault 9
bleue et où est bernardtier après de
semaines d'absence la police consente
enfin à essayer de
comprendre c'est le service de
l'inspecteur Charles deay qui est chargé
de l'enquête d'ordinaire il upe plutôt
de stup et des
murs Charles Deray vous étiez le
directeur d'enquête he dans le le
dossier Simon Weber al pourquoi ce n'est
pas la PJ qui est saisie au départ de
cette AFF alors au départ il y a pas de
de suspission criminelle il y a pas de
fait criminel c'est une disparition
simple comme il y en a des des milliers
en France et la sûreté urbaine dans
laquelle je travaillais a des services
spécialisés qui interviennent sur la
ville et sur le département la PJ elle
est spécialisée sur des affaires plus
importantes avec des R
nationale ou internationale donc on
éétait pas du tout dans ce cadre là vous
lancez les recherches de semaines après
le signalement de sa disparition est-ce
que vous n'avez pas perdu beaucoup de
temps non parce que il n'y avait pas
d'élément qui pouvait confirmer un
assassinat ou des fait criminel c'est
vraiment le la procédure de recherche
dans l'intérêt des familles on essaie
d'avoir des éléments pour savoir s'il y
a autre chose qu'une disparition
simple les policiers surveillent Simon
Weber la prennent en filature et
interrogent ses voisins le couple
hag ceci apporte un témoignage
capital l'après-midi de la disparition
de bernardtier ils ont vu un homme
entrer dans l'immeuble avec Simone
Weber mais ils ne l'ont jamais vu
redescendre pire ils ont entendu des
bruits inquiétants à
l'étage madame Weber puisque c'est elle
dont il s'agissait avait passé une nuit
à utiliser instrument électrique elle
avait descendu au petit matin des sacs
poubelles en quantité importantes
qu'elle les avait placé elle-même dans
le camion elle avait attentendu le
camion des ordures pour mettre ses
poubelles dedans et que ils avaient
regardé sa santé le sang c'est ce qui
m'a été
rapporté incroyable les policiers
placent Simon Weber sur écoute et les
échanges téléphonique qu'elle a avec sa
sœur cadette Madeleine qui vit à Cannes
sont très intéressants Simone et
Madeleine parle d'une certaine
Bernadette qu'il faudrait changer
d'école un nom de code sans aucun doute
on s'est dit B pourquoi Bernadette ce
serait pas la voiture de
Bernard
pourquoi changer d'école ben l' changé
de lieu de stationnement et de là on a
on a on a réussi à à craquer le le
code et ce n'est pas tout à Cann les
découvre que Madeleine loue un box sous
une fausse identité à l'intérieur bingo
la fameuse Bernadette la Renault 9 bleu
de bernardtier équipé de fausses plaques
d'immatriculation une découverte étrange
qui provoque l'interpellation des deux
sœur et dans la foulée une perquisition
fructueuse chez Simon Weber deux
carabines des explosifs et des faux
papiers chez Madeleine à Cann on
retrouve les papiers de la Bernadette
chquier et une carte de sécurité sociale
appartenant à
bernardtier mais surtout dans le coffre
de la voiture un outil de bricolage
interpelle les enquêteurs une meleuse
pour découper du béton loué par Simon
Weber la veille de la disparition de
bernardtier cet engin pouvait
éventuellement avoir servi à
démembrer un
cadavre
la meuleuse est peut-être tout
simplement ce bruit de machine entendu
par les voisins du dessous la nuit qui a
suivi la disparition de Bernard
Itier les deux sœurs sont questionnées
par la police Charles deay quelle est
l'attitude de Simone et de Madeleine
Weber en garde à vue Simone n'a rien
lâché n'a rien dit n'a rien abandonné la
sœur de de Simone Weber est quelqu'un
d'effacé de beaucoup plus timide de
beaucoup plus
gentil et pas le mot mais plus calme que
sa sœur et donc elle a nié lesffit en
bloc comment les deux sœurs
expliquent-elles la présence de la
voiture de Bernard etier dans le box à
Cannes alors la sœur ne s'est jamais
exprimé là-dessus ou très très peu par
contre Simon
Weber a toujours été fidèle à ses
explications c'était pour rendre service
àtier pour pas qu'il a d'ennuie à des
contraventions en la laissant sur la
voie publique amandonné et puis pas
qu'on sache que Bernard Itier faisait
des frasques et avait disparu un certain
temps elle vous menent ça vous agace et
elle vous mena avec talent avec force et
conviction talent je ne sais pas mais
avec
conviction à l'issue de leur garde à vue
Simone et Madeleine sont présentés au
juge d'instruction Gilbert
h le début d'une relation houleuse entre
Simone Weber et son juge une relation
unique dans l'histoire de la
justice gilbertille Vous vous rappelez
votre premier face àface avec Simone
webert oui lorsque je l'inculpe elle me
déclame quelques phrases protestant de
son innocence et ensuite je lui fais
connaître la possibilité qu'elle a de
choisir un avocat elle me dit sans rire
je fais le choix de maître robinet qui
va me laver de tout soupçon je reste
effectivement impassible et je lui
annonce que je la place en détention
provisoire à l'époque c'est le juge
d'instruction qui place en détention
provisoire et elle se comporte comment
avec
vous c'est l'innocence personnifiée pour
quel motif inculpez-vous les deux sœurs
Weber à l'issue de ce premier
interrogatoire Simon Weber est inculpé à
l'époque domicide volontaire et de
quelques dél cononnect diverses et
variés puisqu'il y a notamment des
infractions à la législation sur les
explosifs et les arm puisquon a retrouvé
trois bâtons de dynamite chez elle un
dispositif de mise à feu de carabines
van de long rifle un stock de munition
des timbres de humide de de mairie ou
d'autres institutions de pharmaciens qui
s'averront être dérobé en en divers
lieux Madeleine Weber est inculpée pour
RESSEL du véhicule de bernarti et
également de destruction de preuve
d'éléments à conviction est-ce que la
première fois que vous les voyez elles
semblent inquiète l'une et l'autre non
elles se
défendent de leur petite voix
chantenante mais bon j'en ai vu
d'autres les policiers ont accumulé pas
mal d'indices mais il en manque un et de
taille le corps de Bernard
etier TR mois après sa disparition un
pêcheur de POCI en scène et Marne donne
sans le savoir un coup coup de pou
décisif à l'enquête il repêche une
valise dans la Marne à plus de 300 km de
Nancy et lors qu'il l'ouvre c'est là
qu'on a vu la paire de P quoi on voyait
carrément que c'était une paire de
c'était pas
unon c'est un Tron
humain il faudra 9 mois pour faire le
rapprochement avec bernardtier grâce à
une radio du bassin du disparu comparé à
celle de ce Tron l'expert légiste est
formel c'est bien
lui
ça tangentait les on va dire 999 pour
vous donner une idée c'était quand même
très très très très très
similaire mais 99,9 ce n'est pas 100
% c'est ce que rappelle la défense qui
conteste donc l'identité du
Tron la valise va pourtant livrer un
autre secret des trac d'une peinture
bleue l'analyse de la peinture bleue du
parpin servant à lester la valise était
la même composition que la peinture dans
la maison de Simon Weber sous la
peinture j'ai trouvé des graines de
sable qui étaient les mêmes graines
sable que ceux du jardin de Simone Weber
également les policiers et le juge ont
maintenant un morceau de corps qui
pourrait être celui de Bernard etier et
un scénario qui tient la route selon eux
le meurtre se serait déroulé dans
l'appartement de Simone
Weber un calement lui a peut-être été
administré à son insu et euh il est fort
probable qu'il est soit décédé d'un coup
de V de long rifle et par la suite dans
la nuit elle le découpe en morceaux
après avoir mis des plastiques et pour
protéger le sol elle met dans le camion
d'ordure les sacs
elle utilise également une valise
qu'elle a trouvé chez htier pour y
mettre le tronc sans les membres et le
mobile alors le mobile la jalousie parce
queelle a toujours soupçonné étier
d'avoir des relations féminine nombreus
et elle a vu qu'étier le la lâchait elle
l'a pas
[Musique]
supporté
Simone Weber on a dit que vous aviez un
mobile le dépit amoureux et vous n'avez
pas supporté qu'il a d'autrees femme
vraiment impensable
amoureuse remarquez qu'il y en a qui
tomb amoureux 60 ans je lisais ça dans
un magazine c'est peut-être possible je
dir ça si ça arrive en tout cas pas vous
ben je crois pas faut jamais dire jamais
mais je ne crois
[Musique]
les policiers concentrent maintenant
leurs recherch sur le passé de Simon
Weber ils découvre qu'elle a déjà été
mariée à un militaire retraité veuf et
sans enfant un certain Marcel
Fixard l'homme est mort subitement en
1981 3 ans avant son décès ce monsieur
cherchait une dame de compagnie Simone
Weber s'est présenté a séduit l'homme et
le mariage a été célébré à Strasbourg
les policiers retrouvent l'un des
témoins du mariage et
l'interroge surprise je le connais pas
celui-là je l'ai jamais vu celui-là mais
il était il était pas comme ça elle
commence à nous décrire un homme
qui qui n'avait rien à voir avec Marcel
Fixard Simon Weber est donc soupçonné
d'avoir embauché un figurant pour se
marier un figurant qu'on a jamais
retrouvé et Marcel fix est mort lui 3
semaines seulement après cette union
d'une crise cardiaque alors qu'il était
en bonne santé bizarre d'autant que les
policiers découvrent que Simon s'était
fait prescrire un puissant médicament
pour le cœur de la digitaline et ceci à
l'aide de fausses
ordonnances pour le juge Simon Weber a
un mobile l'argent avec la mort de
Marcel Fixard elle peut toucher
l'héritage du papi un compte en banque
bien garni et une maison à rosiier au
salinees le corps de Marcel Fixard est
exhumé pour vérifier s'il reste des
traces de poison dans les vicères mais
la toxicologue ne trouvera pas
[Musique]
grand-chose à partir du moment vous
n'êtes pas capable de dire c'est à
certainement la digitaline et bien vous
émettez un
doute gilbertine malgré ce doute vous
l'inculpez quand même une deuxième fois
pour l'empoisonnement de Marcel fixal
quand vous avez quelqu'un qui s'est
emparé de la maison de celui qui
deviendra son pseudo mari qui aura
épousé à l'insu de ces derniers et donc
elle captera tous les biens par un faux
Testament et qu'elle aura acheté avec
des ordonnances volées et falsifiées de
la digitaline et bien ma foi j'ai estimé
qu'il y avait des charges suffisantes
pour qu'elle soit jugée également du
chef d'empoisonnement c'est ça le rôle
d'un juge
d'instruction 17 janvier 1991 Simone
Weber comparaît pour deux assassinats
devant la Cour d'assise de mort et
moosel celui de Bernard etier et celui
de Marcel Fixard l'audience est prévue
pour durer 6 semaines un record de
longueur le procès sannonce
spectaculaire et théâtrale Lilian Glock
avocate de Simone Weber était au
première
loge
Lilian Glock est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
pourrait prendre encore 6 semaines pour
juger un crime
passionnel je ne sais pas mais c'est pas
dans l'air du temps il faut dire les
choses hein ça a été un spectacle
euh si vous voulez les les le public qui
quittait la salle le matin ils allaient
à la baraque de frit qui a fait fortune
s'est acheter un sandwich et il
reprenait la queue pour rentrer à 14h
parce que il y avait une file d'attente
à la sortie la salle était comble et on
attendait que une place se se libère
pour venir s'installer ça a été un grand
spectacle j'ai fait dédicacé quelques
livres à Simone Weber et qu'est-ce
qu'elle leur écrivait elle elle était
quand même un peu préoccupée par son
procès elle me disait qu'est-ce que
j'écris je disait bah écoutez marquz
pour Michel la personne qui a demandé
voilà c'est quand même c'est c'est
quelque chose quand
même le cas Marcel Fixard est examiné en
premier mais l'accusation a peu
d'éléments pour charger Simone
Weber pour Bernard etier les indices
matériels et les témoignages sont en
revanche beaucoup plus solides le 28
février 1991 après 11h de délibérer le
verdict est prononcé en l'absence de
Simone Weber transféré à l'hôpital à la
suite d'un
malaise le verdict tombé il y a
seulement quelques minutes la cour
d'assise de Murt et Mosel a condamné
Simone Weber à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle 20 ans pour le meurtre de
Bernard ettier la préméditation n'a pas
été retenue et Simone Weber est acquitté
pour l'assassinat de Marcel
Fixard sa sœur madeleine est condamnée à
18 mois de prison ferme pour avoir
détruit le passeport et le chéquier de
Bernard
etier Lilian Glock que pensez-vous du
verdict qui a été rendu par la Cour
d'Assise 20
ans je pense que
c'est comment on dit quand on parle bien
une côte mal taillée elle est coupable
de
quoi d'avoir tué son amant par jalousie
l'addition est
élevée après sa condamnation Simone
Weber ne baisse pas les bras époque
l'appel n'existe pas pour les verdictes
d'assis toujours combative elle se
pourvoie aussitôt en cassation cé une
forme de logique puisqu'elle a estimé
avoir été victime du juge de la police
de la presse il était normal queelle
aille au bout de sa logique et qu'elle
qu'elle espère bénéficier d'un d'un
autre
procès Simone Weber est finalement
débouttée elle va donc purger sa peine à
la centrale pour femmes de Rennes
elle a été une détenue sans histoire
beaucoup plus facile d'ailleurs que elle
n'avait été lorsqu'elle était en
détention préventive à Nancy où elle
était un petit peu la vedette puisqu'on
parlait très souvent d'elle dans les
journaux et là elle imposait sa loi aux
autres aux autres
détenus Simone Weber partage sa cellule
avec son dossier plus de 18000 pages
qu'elle n'a cessé de lire et de relire
elle a continué pendant toute cette
période à à travailler sur son dossier à
écrire à rechercher des éléments qui
seraient de nature à permettre la
réouverture du du du procès de démontrer
son
innocence mais à ce jour son procès en
révision n'est toujours pas d'actualité
Simone Weber a retrouvé la liberté le 18
novembre
1999 après 14 ans de prison son avocat
était présent le jour de de sa
sortie on a déjeuné ensemble et je l'ai
ramené à horly où elle prenait un avion
pour pour pour aller à Cannes rejoindre
sa sœur j'ai vu que la compagnie avec
laquelle elle voyageait c'est la
compagnie Air Liberté je trouve que sur
le plan symbolique c'était une image
assez extraordinaire tout à fait
forttuite aujourd i Simone Weber vit à
Cann dans la même résidence cossue que
sa sœur madeleine à 85 ans elle est
affaiblie par son âge mais toujours
aussi
combative Simone Weber comment
allez-vous
aujourd'hui ben un jour pas vraiment
bien peux pas bouger mes bras des fois
même pas la main pour prendre une
tasse on le dirait pas comme ça mais
alors quand on est du haut en bas pres
pres que paralysé comme ça on peut rien
faire quand ça va un peu mieux les jours
j'ai moins mal ben il faut faire tout ce
qu'on fait pas quand on n pas quand on a
mal comment vous occupez vos journées
justement que je m'occupe je me lève
très tard et je suis presque tout le
temps
couché sans rire presque tout le temps
couché comment s'est passé votre
détention je lisais puis j'écrivais
j'écrivais tellement que je pouvais plus
écrire tellement j'avais mal dans le
poignet
et non puis je m'occupais des autres de
les aider dans ce qu'elle vivait alors
si j'étais un tas de torchon qui
massacre un homme à la tronçonneuse je
crois pas que je ferais des choses comme
ça on ditvous que vous étiez une détenue
modèle et ben je suis en détention comme
dans la vie de tous les jours je suis
pas le bon Dieu ni la diabolique ni l'un
ni l'autre ça veut dire que vous avvez
accepté votre peine accepté ma peine je
vous dis hein enregistrez-le bien hein
et quand on voit la crapulerie qui
existent hein et les gens qui
assassinent moralement des gens qui ont
jamais fait de choses pareilles et bien
on serait presque mieux
euh en
[Musique]
prison si l'affaire Simone Weber a
marqué les anales judiciaires c'est sans
doute en raison de la personnalité de
l'accusé une mamie au mil000 visages
corias punugace et mystérieuse
elle n'est jamais naturelle elle est
toujours dans la représentation elle est
toujours dans l'excès dans lavective
donc à vrai dire une femme je pense
complète
qui a volontairement évité d'être de se
révéler puisque pendant la procédure
pénale elle a refusé les expertise
psychiatrique ce qui est quand même
assez
[Musique]
rare c'est un peu de docteur jecky et
mrter Hyde elle peut être mielleuse
toute gentille quand elle a besoin de
quelque chose et puis subitement elle
peut changer de de caractère elle très
virulente
méchante une personnalité qui marque
encore les policiers aujourd'hui et qui
les a désarçonné dès le début de
l'enquête quand ils ont commencé leur
filature au début on prenait un petit
peu de distance on disait oh la mamille
elle va jamais nous retapisser hein donc
on prenait pas trop de précaution et
puis plusieurs fois on a remarqué
qu'elle s'arrêtait elle faisait des ce
qu'on appelle en langage policier des
coups de sécurité alors soit elle
s'arrêtait soit elle faisait demi-tour
ou après elle repartait ailleurs il
était évident qu'elle nous avait repéré
donc c'est vrai que à l'époque on se dit
une mamie qui s'amuse à faire ça comme
les grands voyou le font quand ils vont
sur des braquage ou
autre agit comme ça c'est qu'elle a
quelque chose à se reprocher elle ne
manquait pas une occasion de me dire
monsieur deay vous n'est pas un peu
grossi Monsieur Jacques mais vous vous
comportez comme un voyou et il y a que
Monsieur til qui échappé un peu à sa
vindicte Simone Weber Gilbert un duo
atypique et inoubliable ils se sont
affrontés à 75 reprises dans le bureau
du juge une relation parfois orageuse
mais parfois aussi
compiss quand ça se passait bien avec le
juge elle l'appelait mon poussin et puis
quand ça se passait mal entre eux elle
l'appelait
Touvier
Touvier l'ancien chef de la milice de
Lyon une autre fois à la sortie d'un
interrogatoire houleux elle trouve à son
juge un autre surnom il refuse de le
prouver alors c'est un assassinat moral
c'est un band
mais parfois le duo ser R biboche et le
jugetil accepte d'accompagner
discrètement Simone Weber au cimetière
pour se recueillir sur les tombes de
deux de ses enfants
décédés c'est vrai que à l'occasion de
tel moment il peut y avoir des des des
des échanges d'humanité on va dire
d'humanité entre une prévenue et un juge
et un juge d'instruction et puis après
il y a le conflit euh qui résulte du
dossier où chacun a des convictions très
fortes dans un sens opposé et qui fait
que nécessairement par moment c'est ça
devient très très vif gilbertil queles
étaient vos relations avec Simone Weber
comment ça se passa avec elle elle était
respectueux j'étais respectueux de de sa
personne euh j'avais une grosse
difficulté Simon Weber est est quelqu'un
d'intin
dans l'interrogatoire mais qui éprouve
absolument le besoin de justifier tout
et et son contraire donc qui parle sans
arrêt et qui à défaut de toujours
réfléchir suffisamment se met après dans
des des situations un peu délicates pour
elle et vous aussi vous êtes un
instinctif donc comment ça se passait
entre vous et elle par moment il va y
avoir des conflits quand même ah oui des
coups de sang mais enfin bon c'est c'est
un peu ce n'est pas un jeu donc mais
néanmoins on dit c'est le jeu du chat et
de la souris un jour je lui ai dit moi
j'ai passé le concours de chat vous vous
êtes titulaire du diplôme de la souris
mais on était un peu comme un vieux
couple alors parfois on se disputait
parfois c'était beaucoup plus plus
calme dans une ambiance beaucoup plus
zine en même temps vous aviez avec elle
des relations étranges vous l'avez même
sorti de prison pour l'emmener voir ses
enfants au cimetière c'est pas tout à
fait légal ça vous trouvez quoi
destranches là-dedans non mais c'est pas
tout à fait légal est-ce que c'est
illégal non donc je l'ai fait à 5 ou si
reprises alors certains ont dit ouais
vous faites ça pour obtenir des saves
mais c'est absolument ridicule il y a un
minimum d'humanité et si cette humanité
doit comporter quelques prise de risque
ben prenons-les Simone Weber vous avez
une relation un peu particulière avec
gilbertil non pas particulière j'ai
jamais eu de haine de toute façon contre
lui je me doute bien que quand à
longueur de journée
qu'on interroge des gros des gros
bagnards des grosses scrapules ça doit
machiner les esprits à le cerveau et
vous regrettez de l'avoir appelé mon
bandit quand j'ai dit ça c'était dans le
hall du tribunal ça m'est sorti un
bandit et je dit je m'excuse
monsieur vous savez ça m'est sorti comme
ça
mais c'était c'est pas ce que je
pense gilbertil les avocats Weber vous
ont accusé de vous acharner contre elle
parce que vous l'aviez maintenu en
détention provisoire pendant 5 ans
madame Weber a fait la greffe de
l'instruction pendant près d'une année
je répète qu'elle a déposé une plainte
au pénal contre moi qui étit rejetée
qu'elle a multiplié les manœuvres
dilatoires et que de sur quoi elle a
parfois simulé de faux malaises
authentifié médicalement comme de faux
malaisees dans mon cabinet j'ai fait le
plus vite que je pouvais et s'il y a une
chose pour laquelle je me suis Charné
c'est de d'essayer de découvrir la
vérité une vérité qui ne convient
toujours pas à Simone Weber 30 ans après
elle a tenu à passer un message à son
juge Simone Weber qu'est-ce que vous
avez envie de dire à
gilbertil je me demande comment il a pu
faire ça vraiment parce que s'il avait
fait une enquête propre parce que c'est
une
enquête crapuleuse vous pouvez le lui
dire d'abord il le sait hein il le sait
qu'un homme comme lui fabrique une
criminelle de cette
façon-là c'est c'est triste je ne
comprends pas je peux pas comprendre B
il y a rien de neuf sous le soleil et
notamment sous le soleil de canen j'ai
l'impression d'entendre madame
Weber pendant l'instruction ou après sa
condamnation elle soutient que c'est
l'innocence crucifié d'autres qui
avaient la charge de la juger en ont
décidé autrement voilà vous n'êtes plus
juge d'instruction aujourd'hui que fait
que faites-vous
rien je suis 2èe adjoint maire de de
Nancy en charge des questions de
sécurité charger le naturel il revient
au
[Musique]
Galot dans l'affaire Simone Weber la
justice s'est donné les moyens plus de 5
années d'instruction 18000 pages de
procès verbaux des dizaines d'expertises
de fouilles et de perquisition on a
vraiment tout tout tout essayé je veux
dire les analyses de
peinture les analyses de boud d'os on
allait dans les cuvettes de toilettes
aller chercher des poils à un moment
donné je crois que on a même vidé un
canal pour tenter pour tenter d'aller
trouver
des restes humains et quand on faisait
une expertise et que l'expertise ne
convenait pas à la thèse de l'accusation
mais on faisait une contreexpertise puis
la
contreexpertise elle convenait convenait
un peu plus pu on en faisait une trè
pour arriver pour arriver finalement à à
conforter ce qu'on
estimait être être une charge la défense
été avec un lancepierre contre une
division de de char
blindé
Lilian Glock est-ce que le jugetil s'est
acharné contre Simon Weber dans une
affaire comme celle-là faire assécher un
canal comme chacun sait ça tire une
fortune de la poche du contribuable
c'est quand même une certaine forme
d'acharnement on a changé au 21e siècle
quand un juge entend ordonner des
diligences qui coûtent très cher on
s'enquierre d'abord du prix et on voit
si on le fait ou non si le jeu en vaut
la chandelle elle a coûté cher cette
enquête à la justice elle a coûté
d'après la Cour Régionale des Comptes
500000 francs ce qui n'est pas rien et
bon raisonnablement c'était pas justifié
alors est-ce qu'aujourd'hui une enquête
comme celle-ci pourrait avoir lieu être
mené de cette façonlà aussi longtemps je
vois mal la chambre de l'instruction de
la cour d'appel de Nancy actuellement
dans une affaire comme ça garder
quelqu'un 6 ans en détention
provisoire gilbertin on peut dire que
dans C affaire vous n'avez pas lesiné
sur les moyens certainement pas vous
connaissez la formule on disait que la
justice n'a pas de prix c'est pour ça
qu'elle a un coup mais enfin cette
complainte parce que je me souviens bien
que ça m'a été reproché c'est dire la
pauvreté quand même ça je tiens à le
dire du raisonnement de certains avocats
si vous ne faites pas certaines
expertises il vous les reprochent et
quand ils n'ont plus à faire preuve que
de poujadisme pour dire cette affaire a
coûté cher à l'époque c'était 500000
francs et ben je plains ceci qui se
prête endre les défenseurs des libertés
et des droits individuels de venir de
dire ça a coûté de l'argent donc ça
c'est le genre d'argument que je
n'accepte pas et je sais d'où il
vient Simone Weber elle non plus n'a pas
lésiné sur les moyens pour se défendre
pas moins de 25 avocats se sont relayés
auprès d'elle il faut dire que ce n'est
pas simple d'être l'avocat de
Simone quand ça se passait mal avec un
avocat ou que l'avocat ne ne faisait pas
ce que Simon voulait
elle l'éjectait et c'est ce qui fait
aussi
que les avocats lui passa beaucoup de
choses il y en a qui n'ont fait que
passer et parmi ces avocats de passage
plusieurs grands noms Garau Collard
Pelletier et
vergess vergess avait dit que avait fait
de Simon Weber une créature qui avait
les auts de Marie benénard et les
couilles de landendru c'est très imagé
c'est c'était une bonne formule que tout
le monde a repris elle a pas du tout
apprécié ce trait d'humour elle a si peu
apprécié que le ténor a été congédié sur
le champ par sa
cliente 30 ans après malgré les moyens
engagés par la justice des zones d'ombre
demeurent dans l'affaire Weber
aujourd'hui encore l'identité du corps
repêché dans la Marne fait toujours
l'objet de vif débat je sais pas si vous
avez déjà vu un Tron mais il y a rien
qui ressemble plus à un Tron qu'un autre
Tron au début on pense que c'est le Tron
d'un homme de couleur mais le Tron ayant
séjourné longtemps dans l'eau euh il y a
une dégradation et il y a le problème
d'une cicatrice qui résulterait d'une
opération de
l'appendicite tous les dossiers médicaux
de bernardtier avaient été saisis et à
aucun moment aucun moment aucun dossier
médical ne faisait état d'une opération
de l' perdicde donc c'est clair c'était
pas le Tron de Monsieur Itier pour moi
c'est pas une zone d'ombre c'est c'est
le Tron bernardtier parce que bon
l'autopsie a mis en évidence des points
de concordance sur les point d'arthrose
sur les déformations squeltiques bon le
le en plus il y a le groupe sanguin qui
est qui est
identique à l'époque l'identification
par ADN était une technique balbuciante
elle il a été tenté sur le Tron mais n'a
rien donné car il avait séjourné trop
longtemps dans
l'eau aujourd'hui ça serait super simple
je veux dire ADN recherche d'ADN il y a
bien évidemment des preuves de l'ADN de
Monsieur étier vivant on aurait été voir
si le le corps était porteur de la même
ADN autre zone d'ombre le décès de
Marcel Fixard Simon Weber a été acquitté
faute de présence significative de
digitaline dans la dépouille du vieux
monsieur serait-elle acquitté
aujourd'hui le doute est
permis depuis 25 ou 30 ans les
recherches en toxicologie ont grandement
avancé on aurait pu peut-être savoir si
oui ou non le corps de Monsieur Fixard
était imbibé de de digitaline ceci dit
la digitaline avait justement cette
propriété de très vite se décomposer
disparaître donc sur ce point
je ne peux pas vous répondre de manière
[Musique]
certaine 30 ans après l'atrocité du
crime de Simone Weber reste vivace pour
la famille de Bernard etier d'autant
plus que le deuil a été difficile faute
de
corps ce que je vais vous dire est
absolument horrible la famille a
récupéré de beaucoup je dire c'est c'est
des mots et une image qui correspondent
pas du tout à nos à nos traditions de
deuil dans notre société et que c'est
avec ça qu'on qu'on doit faire un
simulacre d'enterrement et de cérémonie
c'est terrible je pense que là c'est une
PL qui restera béante chez Patricia
[Musique]
ETTI Patricia Itier aujourd'hui vous
êtes toujours
amère parce qu'elle nous a détruit
détruit la famille qui me
restait mon père c'était tout
quoi le fait que Simon Weber soit sorti
de prison h et
qu'elle vive à Cann h soleil tranquille
coule des jours heureux c'est honteux
déjà elle a été condamnée qu' a 20 ans
d'emprisonnement mais 20 ans elle les a
pas fait elle en a fait 14 hein la bonne
mamie tranquille on l' relâché quoi
donc maintenant voà
elle est tranquille mais moi je serai
pas sine tant que je sais qu'elle est là
c'est-à-dire tant qu'elle est vivante et
encore je pense que on souffrira pas
comme elle a fait souffrir les autres
Simon Weber continue de se dire
innocente h qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez je me demande comment elle peut
dormir et comment elle peut encore se
regarder dans une glace je veux dire moi
je je sais pas comment on peut vivre
avec ça vous aimeriez qu'elle av vouse
oui ça me soulagerait je parce que je
voudrais quand même bien savoir ce
qu'elle a fait du restant de de papa
quoi je je voudrais bien à votre avis
qu'est-ce que ça changerait ça
changerait peut-être rien vis-à-vis de
de la vie parce que maintenant bon faut
se faire une raison
mais j'aurais au moins la satisfaction
de m'être battu pour trouver la vérité
puis savoir exactement ce qui s'est
passé et alors vous aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous devenez on vit avec
heureusement que j'ai eu ma fille j'ai
une fille qui arrivé un petit peu avant
le procès ça m'a soutenu dans mon dans
mes efforts je me suis battu aussi un
petit peu pour elle pour son grand-père
quoi mais bon j'y pense quoi c'est comme
si c'était tout frais encore dans ma
mémoire
[Musique]
quoi depuis sa condamnation Simon Weber
a eu de nouveau affire à la justice mais
cette fois-ci en sa faveur elle avait
été condamnée pour son mariage avec
Marcel Fixard et pourtant elle a pu
rester la veuve de son faux
mari le parquet n'a pas fait annuler le
mariage c'est un acte civil il faut le
faire annuler donc voilà elle est
toujours mariée à Marcel
Fixard une situation qui a longtemps
laissé planer un doute sur l'héritage
Fixard composé notamment de la maison de
rosiero
saline Simone Weber pouvait-elle la
conserver la justice a
tranché il y a quelques
années le fisque a adressé une
réclamation à Madame Weber une
réclamation de taxe foncière sur la
maison de risier Rossal on a sais le
tribunal
administratif en disant mais attendez de
deux choses l'une soit madame Weber
n'est pas n'est plus propriétaire de
cette maison en vertu de la
de la Cour d'Assise auquel cas les les
les impôts locaux ne sont pas dû soit si
vous déclarez que les taxes fiscales
sont dus c'est qu'elle est propriétaire
et qu'est-ce qu'il a dit le tribunal
administratif le tribunal administratif
il a validé l'imposition au titre de la
taxe foncière donc reconnaissant ainsi
que Simon Weber était propriétaire de
cette
maison Simone Weber n'est plus
propriétaire de cette maison car elle
l'a vendu il y a 4
ans Simon Weber est toujours aussi jeune
d'esprit puisque a passé 80 ans mais
elle s'est toujours tirer profit de ses
anciens magouillages pour hériter d'un
homme avec lequel elle ne s'est vraiment
jamais
marié aujourd'hui Simone Weber vit avec
ses souvenirs et ses secrets elle
continue d'explorer les méandres de son
dossier pour faire triompher sa
vérité
qu'est-ce que vous cherchez dans ces
18000 pages prouver mon
innocence parce que j'ai une tête à
aller jouer de la tronneuse quelqu'un
qu'on aime bien aujourd'hui Simon Weber
ce que vous aimeriez c'est la révision
de votre procès oui pour cela il faut un
élément nouveau et vous pensez que vous
l'aurez un jour je vous dis pas pourquoi
je vous le dirai après je vous
appellerai quand vous
l'aurez il vous arrive aujourd'hui de de
repenser à bernarétier oui parce que
j'aimais bien
bernartier j'étais pas sa maîtresse
comme les crapulas ont inventé
et moi l'amitié c'est quelque chose qui
compte énormément cette affaire Simon
Weber a eu de nombreuses répercussions
sur votre famille et ben sur mon fils ça
l'a vraiment démoli mais démoli
d'abord il
était qui se travaillait mal qu'il avait
quitté son travail et tout et tout dans
les de ça et tout ça c'est à cause de
cette affaire oui oui et ça ça peut pas
être
supportable c'est pas supportable vous
avez une autre fille Daniel oui qui elle
ne vous parle plus non pourquoi
elle me l'a jamais dit
et
je ne lui ai jamais demandé votre sœur
Madeleine elle vous soutient encore
aujourd'hui ah oui mais
elle veut pas en entendre parler alors
si elle voit un truc qui est marqué dans
le journal on parle de justice de police
elle attrape se dit ça t'intéresse
encore la justice vous avez pensé à un
moment donné à écrire un livre il y en a
une partie
d'écrite comment il s'appelle au nom des
innocents
justice qui es-tu j'avais déjà écrit en
en partie ce que je voulais dire euh à
reen alors si ça se trouve il me faudra
la deuxième vie pour
finir le jour où vous partirez dans
l'autre monde là
euh je ne crois plus trop à l'autre
monde
euh voir avoir vu des choses comme ça
qu'il faut porter euh tant d'années on
peut pas croire au bon Dieu non pour
euh quelqu'un qui voulait entre Carmel
pu croire au bon Dieu ça fait drôle hein